well done by miles bridges and there is
your 19 year old kia nba rookie of the
year
congratulations right now thank you
thank you
all right lamella let's start here uh
and i'm going to
show my age because when i was growing
up
my favorite player to watch was pete
maravich and when i watch you play and
you can watch online people have seen
your clips the way you pass the ball is
unbelievable one of my favorites is that
length of the court uh
underhand uh right on right on target
so who is your biggest influence about
the way you play the game
so honestly i watched a lot of people
but honestly pistol pete too because i
remember my pops
showing me a movie from him but a lot of
people's game i really like to look at
penny hardaway katie curry
i mean magic johnson it's a lot of
greats you know pretty much just
look at everybody though together and at
the end throw a little bit of my own
stuff on it
the mellow shack here i don't have any
questions i i've been
seeing you play ever since you're young
so you're still a youngster just want to
say you should be proud your family
should be proud
congratulations and uh uh may god
continue to bless your young men
yes sir thank you chef good luck uh
number one congratulations
what was the easiest and what was the
hardest thing about your rookie year
uh the easiest the easiest is just
showing up being there i mean it's
basketball so that's pretty much come
easy to me and then the hardest
i'm have to say without playing with
fans the whole corona thing
waking up for the testing that was only
that's probably the hardest thing i'd
say
you know congratulations uh again
uh i've gotten a chance to watch you
since probably fifth and sixth grade
on the aau search i remember that you've
been
done had some good battles with you and
your brothers and you were the youngest
of them all
you know the one thing that i would say
you know
you took the unconventional route to the
nba right
uh when you look back on it do you think
that it helped you
or not really or it maybe hindered you
that unconventional route to the league
yeah
i'm gonna definitely say help me and
like i said like i say i'm one of one
all that so
i feel like it just fits me and it's who
i am for real
let me ask you this too because you you
started the year coming off the bench
when did you first start thinking you
know what rookie of the year might be a
possibility here
uh i mean honestly way before way before
the league honestly
when i was playing basketball and then
they was talking about the nba stuff
that's when i knew
if i'm a rookie that's probably one of
the accomplishments i could get
and then pretty much the whole bench
thing i mean i i didn't really have too
many problems with that because i knew i
was going to get in and get some time so
i'm like the time i'm gonna get
i'm obviously gonna make something out
of it and then hopefully that leads to
other things what you did and then
everything worked how it should work
lamella ball got 84 out of 99 first
place
votes anthony edwards got the other 15
and the kia
nba rookie of the year sits before you
there lamello ball congratulations man
thank you man thank you phil hills is in
the building